This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听由您最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）为您带来的《艰难的教训》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难的教训》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
那是iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方的TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他别想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into it, I just want to let you know that this episode involves discussions of sexual assault, harassment, and trauma. So if those subjects are things that you're particularly sensitive to, please just consider whether this is the right time to be listening to this episode
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时最大的改变、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。在我们深入探讨之前，我只想让大家知道，本集涉及对性侵犯、骚扰和创伤的讨论。因此，如果你对这些主题特别敏感，请考虑现在是否是收听本集的合适时机
and just make sure to take care of yourself. There will be additional resources in the episode description. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. You listeners, old listeners, it's so great to have you back. Today, I'm just going to cut right to the chase. We're talking about sex. More specifically, we're going to talk about why some of us are just not that interested. Why there are these periods where, you know, sex just kind of loses its appeal and, like, isn't really enjoyable. I think we've been fed this story that your 20s are this decade of peak sexual desire,
并确保照顾好自己。本集简介中将提供额外的资源。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。各位听众，老听众们，很高兴你们能回来。今天，我就直奔主题了。我们来谈谈性。更具体地说，我们要谈谈为什么我们中的一些人其实对此并不是那么感兴趣。为什么会有这样一些时期，你知道，性就这样失去了吸引力，而且，好像，真的不是那么享受。我想我们都被灌输了这样一种说法：你的二十岁是你性欲达到顶峰的十年，
passion, magnetism, sensuality, sexual confidence, you know, we might picture ourselves having as much sex as possible and all the sex is good and, you know, whatever. I don't think that picture is necessarily reality and what if instead you feel kind of distant from your body, unenthusiastic about sex, disconnected from your partner, or maybe just your own sensuality. To be super candid, and I know my parents listen to the podcast, so mom, dad, family members, you can skip this one, but I feel like I've been quite open about some just like random scary health stuff that has been going on this year. And my libido has really been impacted by that. It is definitely at an all-time low. I'm also in a long-term relationship.
充满激情、吸引力、感官享受、性自信，你知道，我们可能会想象自己尽可能多地做爱，而且所有的性都是美好的，你知道，诸如此类。我不认为这种画面必然是现实，而如果你反而觉得和自己的身体有点疏离，对性毫无热情，与伴侣断联，或者也许只是和自己的性感断联，会怎么样呢？坦白讲，我知道我父母会听这个播客，所以妈妈、爸爸、家人们，你们可以跳过这一集，但我觉得我已经很坦诚地谈到了一些今年发生的随机且吓人的健康问题。我的性欲确实受到了这方面的影响。它绝对降到了历史最低点。我也处于一段长期恋爱关系中，
and that can be really hard to navigate when honestly like you just you feel you just don't want sex and it's not because of them at all it's just because your body feels so tired you're under so much stress like there's so much uncertainty hormonally all of these things are happening behind the scenes and it feels kind of awkward to talk about it and it feels like not something that we openly discuss when it is super super normal so if that's you um i just want to like you know you're not the only one i'm definitely in that boat right now i know a lot of other people in their 20s are and you know i've learned from just like talking to my friends and people i know about this that like it's so much more common than you think to just like sometimes just lose a lot of interest
老实说，当你只是不想做爱时，这真的很难驾驭，这完全不是因为对方，而只是因为你的身体感觉太累了，你承受着这么大的压力，有那么多的不确定性，激素方面，所有这些事情都在幕后发生，而且谈论这件事让人觉得有点尴尬，感觉这不是我们公开讨论的事情，尽管它其实超级超级正常。所以如果那是你，嗯，我只是想让你知道，你不是一个人，我目前绝对也在那条船上，我知道其他许多二十多岁的人也是如此，而且你知道，我从与朋友和认识的人谈论这件事中了解到，有时候失去很大的兴趣其实比你想象的要常见得多，
and just to have a low libido and just to be adjusting to your your sexuality and your sensuality and like a new decade and a new period of your life with sex you know it's so easy it would be It's so easy to assume that everyone else is having more sex and better sex than you are. And I think shame just acts as a barrier for any meaningful conversation around this and for any kind of hope for understanding ourselves a little bit better. So we're just going to do away with that today and talk about it openly. Talk about why sometimes our libido fluctuates, why it's really common in your 20s, what might be happening behind this.
而且性欲低下只是在适应你的性欲、你的性感，以及伴侣关系的新十年和生活的新时期，你知道，这太容易了，假设其他人都有更多、更好的性生活是如此容易。我认为羞耻感只是阻碍围绕这个话题进行任何有意义的对话，以及阻碍任何更好地理解我们自己的希望的障碍。所以我们主要要在今天消除这种情绪，并公开谈论它。谈谈为什么我们的性欲有时会波动，为什么这在你二十多岁时非常普遍，这背后可能发生了什么。
scenes in your brain with your hormones and maybe some of the broader ways that you can kind of get back to this feeling of pleasure and this feeling of connection with another person or with yourself. So I'm super excited to jump into this topic today. I hope you are too. Without further ado, let's talk about sex and why you might not want any right now. Stay with us. I think we tend to think that some people just like sex more than others. But really, unless you're someone who is asexual and experiences no or very limited sexual attraction, most of us, our desires change over time quite intensely, depending on our season of life. Our libido is not this static concept that is one way or the other way.
大脑和荷尔蒙方面的场景，以及也许你可以重新找回这种快乐感和与另一个人或与自己建立联系的感觉的一些更广泛的方法。所以我非常高兴能深入探讨今天的话题。希望你也是。废话不多说，我们来谈谈性，以及为什么你现在可能一点都不想做。请继续收听。我想我们往往会认为有些人就是比其他人更喜欢性。但实际上，除非你是无性恋者，没有任何或非常有限的性吸引力，否则我们大多数人的欲望会随着时间的推移而发生非常剧烈的变化，这取决于我们所处的生命阶段。我们的性欲不是一个一成不变的概念。
It's incredibly dynamic. It's something that evolves depending on what's going on for you mentally and environmentally. Sometimes even by the second, it can be really high and then really low. Now a low libido doesn't necessarily mean the absence of wanting sex. Sometimes it just feels more like an underlying, just not discomfort, but just apathy. You know, you may care about your partner, love your partner, think they're really hot, think they're amazing, want their affection, want the emotional bond, but when like that moment arrives, you just can't get into it.
它是极其动态的。它会根据你在精神上和环境上面临的情况而演变。有时甚至每秒钟都在变化，可以非常高然后又非常低。现在，性欲低下并不一定意味着完全不想做爱。有时它更像是一种潜在的、倒算不上不舒服，而只是冷漠的感觉。你知道，你可能关心你的伴侣、爱你的伴侣、觉得他们真的很辣、觉得他们很棒、想要他们的爱抚、想要情感纽带，但当那个时刻到来时，你就是无法进入状态。
how I've described it in the past is like when someone offers you something that you think will be really yummy that it could be literally your favorite food but you're kind of full anyways like you just you could take it or leave it you just not really like you're not hungry you don't really want it still your favorite food but you know you won't enjoy it you know you won't enjoy it just based on how you're feeling so you leave it it's actually totally normal to go through periods like this but what makes this experience pretty difficult is not the fluctuation itself. It's the meaning we attached to it. I came across the survey done in 2021 by researchers at the Kinsey Institute at Indiana University.
我过去是如何形容它的，就像有人递给你一件你觉得会非常美味的东西，那可能字面意义上就是你最喜欢的食物，但无论如何你已经有点饱了——你吃不吃都行，你只是不太像——你并不饿，你其实并不想要它，它依然是你最喜欢的食物，但你知道你不会享受它，根据你当时的感受你知道你不会享受它，所以你就不吃了。经历这样的时期其实完全正常，但让这种经历变得相当艰难的，不是波动本身。而是我们赋予它的意义。我偶然看到金赛研究所（The Kinsey Institute）印第安纳大学的研究人员在2021年进行的一项调查。
They specialize in research on sex, on relationships, on well-being, and they teamed up with the sex retailer, Love Honey, to conduct a survey amongst married adults age 18 to 45. And what they really wanted to know was like these participants, perspectives on sexual desire. What they found was that 11% of people who were born after 1997 and who were also married reported problems with sexual desire that they were lacking it in the past year. And this increased to over 25% for people who were between the ages of, I think it was like 27 and like 41.
他们专门研究性、人情关系和幸福感，他们与性零售商Love Honey合作，对18至45岁的已婚成年人进行了调查。他们真正想知道的是这些参与者对性欲的看法。他们发现，在1997年以后出生且已婚的人中，有11%的人报告说在过去一年中存在性欲问题，缺乏性欲。而对于年龄在，我记得是27到41岁之间的人群，这一比例上升到了25%以上。
A lot of people are having this problem. A further study that was conducted in France in 2010 looked at a random sample of over 2,300 respondents aged 15 to 24, and what the results showed was that a lack of sexual desire were really, really commonly cited problems, especially amongst women. 24% of these women aged 15 to 24, reported experiencing a lack of sexual desire, either sometimes or often compared to only 10% of male respondents. And that doesn't even account for the people who don't report it, because they feel weird about it.
许多人都有这个问题。法国在2010年进行的另一项研究调查了2300多名年龄在15至24岁之间的随机受访者样本，结果显示，缺乏性欲是一个非常非常普遍被提及的问题，尤其是在女性当中。在这些15至24岁的女性中，24%的人报告说有时或经常经历缺乏性欲，而男性受访者中这一比例仅为10%。这甚至还没有算上那些因为觉得怪异而没有报告的人。
Again, what makes this 10 times harder is the expectation we have about sex because of the narratives we've been told by society, especially when we're not feeling this spark. You know, we do assume everybody's having more sex than us. The thing is, that's actually not the case. That's really, like, it definitely isn't the case, especially if you're in your 20s, like most people aren't having great sex and they aren't having the best sex of their lives. This is not even close to like your peak of sexual desire or
同样，由于社会传递给我们的叙事，尤其是当我们感受不到这种火花时，我们对性抱有的期望让这难上十倍。你知道，我们确实假设每个人都比我们有更多的性生活。问题是，事实并非如此。这真的，就像，绝对不是这样的，尤其是如果你正处于二十多岁，就像大多数人并没有很棒的性生活，也没有经历他们一生中最棒的性生活。这甚至都还谈不上是你的性欲顶峰或
sexual maturity yet. A lot of research points to men in particular, their sexual desire peaking around the mid-20s. For women, a really different picture. A 2010 study published in the journal, personality and individual differences found that women's sense. sexual desire actually peaks between 30 to 45. And obviously, that's a pretty large age group, but almost the majority of people in that age bracket reported significantly higher desire levels compared to the younger women aged 18 to 27. We absolutely need to get rid of this narrative that your 20s are the best, the best in
性成熟期。大量研究指出，尤其是男性的性欲在二十岁中期左右达到顶峰。对于女性来说，情况则完全不同。发表在《个性与个体差异》杂志上的一项2010年研究发现，女性的性欲实际上在30到45岁之间达到顶峰。显然，这是一个相当大的年龄段，但该年龄段中几乎大多数人报告的欲望水平明显高于18到27岁的年轻女性。我们绝对需要摆脱这样一种说法，即你的二十岁是最好的，无论在什么方面都是最好的，但在性方面，特别是对于这一集来说。这根本不是真的。就像，这根本不是真的。我们如何理解欲望，要比这复杂得多。你的性欲不仅受你认为自己应该有什么感觉以及你对欲望的渴望的影响。它受到远远超出你控制的事情的影响，而这些事情实际上随着你年龄的增长最终会趋于稳定和改变。在你二十多岁的时候，无论你觉得自己把生活理得有多顺，都会发生很多情绪波动，随着年龄的增长，这些波动会逐渐趋于缓和。正因为如此，就像，你真的有了更多的心智空间去专注于性感，专注于你在身体里的感受。所以让我们来谈谈是什么影响了性欲。让我们来谈谈是什么可能让你不那么享受性爱，并不太
anything really, but like sex, especially for this episode. It's just not true. Like, it's just not true. And how we understand desire, it's just way more complex than that. Your libido isn't just influenced by what you think you should be feeling and your desire for desire. It's influenced by things that go way beyond your control and that actually end up stabilizing and changing the older you get. There's so many emotional fluctuations going on in your 20s, no matter how together you feel about it, that kind of mellow out, the older you get. And because of that, like, you really are a given more mental space to focus on sensuality and to focus on how you feel in your body. So let's talk about what influences libido. Let's talk about what might be making you not enjoy sex as much, not really
想要它。当我们想到这一点时，我觉得你首先会认为我要谈论的是什么？你大概猜对了。荷尔蒙。荷尔蒙是很多人责怪的东西。荷尔蒙确实发挥了作用，但不是以机械的、一维的方式。它们实际上不会引起欲望。就像荷尔蒙并不能决定你是否感到性感一样。它们只是信使。欲望首先也是最重要的是心理上的。然后荷尔蒙将来自大脑的信号，以及来自你的生活、情绪和环境的信号传递出去，这些信号影响着身体的感受。当然，如果那里的某些东西失去了平衡，如果有什么东西没有按它应有的方式运作，这基本上就意味着承载这些消息的所有道路，以及贯穿你身体的、让你感觉良好、性感并被激起欲望的根基，就像被没有运作的交通堵塞了。这意味着根本没有沟通。即使你感到欲望，有时它也不会在你的身体里发生。也许你的身体感受到了欲望。它并没有在你的大脑里发生。我们还得谈谈避孕药。
want it. When we think about this, I feel like what's the first thing that you're going to think I'm going to speak about? You're probably right. Hormones. Hormones are the things that a lot of people blame. And hormones do play a role, but not in like a mechanical, like one dimensional way. They actually don't cause desire. Like your hormones aren't what determines whether you feel sexy or not. They're just the messengers. Desire is first and foremost, mental. And then your hormones carry signals from your brain and then also from your life, from your emotions and your environment that influence how this feels in the body. Now of course, if something's off balance there, if something isn't working the way that it should, it just basically means that all the roads
这以一种非常有趣的方式进入了画面。许多激素避孕药实际上是通过改变大脑和卵巢之间的信息交流来发挥作用的。本质上，它们让本会在整个月中此起彼伏的激素循环变得安静。对某些人来说，这创造了一种情感和生理上的稳定感。他们可能会觉得自己受到更多调节、更加安定、不那么不知所措，但对其他人来说，同样的
that carry these messages and the roots throughout your body that allow you to feel good and sexy and turned on, like they're clogged with traffic that is not working. And so it means that there's just no communication. Even if you feel desire, sometimes it doesn't happen in your body. Maybe your body feels desire. It doesn't happen in your mind. We have to also talk about birth control.
稳定感可能会让人感觉更像是一种压制，不仅压制了你的情绪或荷尔蒙，还压制了你体内那种滋养欲望的火花。有趣的是，激素避孕药物会降低体内循环的睾酮水平，众所周知，睾酮是参与性动机的一种荷尔蒙，这不仅仅针对男性。就像对女性来说，睾酮也非常非常重要。这可能会让人更难进入状态。特别是如果你刚刚开始服用避孕药，这需要很大的调整。你的身体就像在试图弄清楚这个新身体和这个新大脑。
This enters the picture in a really interesting way. Many hormonal contraceptives actually work by changing the communication between the brain and the ovaries. Essentially, they quieten the hormonal cycle that would otherwise kind of ebb and flow throughout the month. And for some people, this creates kind of like an emotional and physiological steadiness. They might feel more regulated, more settled, less overwhelmed, but for others, that same
有些人实际上报告说，在服用避孕药后，他们感受到了更多的欲望，因为他们实际上感觉更安全了。就像他们不再害怕怀孕一样。他们经历的痛苦更少了。他们的周期在情绪上变得不那么不稳定。他们的神经系统有了放松的空间。所以这对每个人来说都可以非常不同，就像荷尔蒙和性对每个人来说都可以不同一样。
steadiness can feel more like a dampening, not just of your mood or your hormones, but of like the spark inside your body that kind of feeds desire. The interesting thing is, hormonal birth control can lower circulating testosterone in the body, which is, as we know, a hormone involved in sexual motivation, not just if you're a guy. Like, for women as well, testosterone is really, really important. And this may make it harder to feel in the mood. Especially if you've just gone on birth control, like, it's a big adjustment. Your body's like trying to figure out this new body and this new mind.
现在，这当然比单纯的生物反应要深得多。我常说的一句话是，性是心理上的，不仅仅是生理上的。它比生理上更具心理性，至少对我来说是这样。如果有什么情绪上的或压力大的事情一直在给欲望踩刹车，荷尔蒙就无能为力——你的性欲将会很低。用来解释这一现象最有用的框架之一来自性反应的双重控制理论。这同样是由我前面提到的金赛研究所的研究人员开发的。
Some people actually report feeling more desire once they're on birth control because they actually feel safer. Like they no longer fear pregnancy. They experience less pain. their cycle becomes less emotionally destabilizing. Their nervous system has space to relax. So it can be really different for everybody, the same way that hormones and sex can be different for everybody.
该模型解释说，我们的性反应是兴奋和抑制过程之间平衡的产物。这个兴奋系统把脚踩在油门上。它就像是，我们要冲啦！它注意到吸引力。它注意到触觉、幻想、情感亲密、温暖、唤醒。另一个系统，即抑制系统，就像把脚踩在刹车上。这是对压力、焦虑、分心、工作繁重等事物做出反应的部分，
Now, this of course goes much deeper than just biological reactions. Something I always say is like sex is mental, not just physical. It's a lot more mental than physical, at least for me. And if there is something emotional or stressful that keeps putting the brakes on desire, hormones are not, like your libido is going to be low. One of the most helpful frameworks we have to explain this comes from the dual control theory of sexual response. This was developed again by researchers at the Kinsey Institute that I mentioned earlier.
经历那场友谊争吵，感觉生活一团糟。而且，它同样是关闭欲望的系统。这些研究人员解释说，大多数时候，低欲望、低性欲并不是因为油门失灵。并不是因为你没有被唤醒或不想做爱。而是因为刹车踩得太猛了。在稍事休息后，让我们进一步探讨这个理论。2%。
And what this model explains is that our sexual responses are a product between this balance of excitory and inhibitory processes. This excitatory system puts the foot on the accelerator. It's like let's freaking go. It notices attraction. It notices touch, fantasy, emotional closeness, warmth, arousal. The other system, the inhibitory system, is like putting your foot on the break. This is the part that responds to things like stress, anxiety, distraction, work sucking,
这就是在也有扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。世界上让我们感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是TWO
having that friendship fight, feeling like your life is chaotic. And it's, again, the system that turns desire off. And what these researchers explain is that most of the time, low desire, low libido, it's not that the accelerator isn't working. It's not that you're not turned on or don't want sex. It's because the break is being pressed too hard. Let's explore the theory a little bit more after this short break. 2%.
percent，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。搞什么鬼？乔治·布什和杀死一小部分人有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked doubt about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时准备谈论毒品，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论过毒品的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell? Does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
谢谢你完成这句话。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的经验
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我在心理健康领域的亲身经历，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这东西。而我们还在继续追逐。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢与输的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio App。搜索Learn the Hard Way并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中的明显矛盾。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。埃伦斯，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
格雷格·莱斯利和迈克尔·马拉基尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈指控被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里，天呐，这是同一个人。
Greg Alespian and Michael Maranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，去你的吧。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他别想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方。所以你可以非常非常深爱一个人，非常非常被他们吸引，非常迷恋他们，却依然感受不到性欲。而这种欲望之火正在被扑灭，不是因为你缺乏欲望。那不是原因。它正被你生活中更广泛的因素所扑灭。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
我们的性欲，就像我听人说的那样，基本上反映了我们在特定时刻感到的安全感。你被唤醒、连接、敞开心扉的能力。取决于你的神经系统是否感到足够平静来允许你这样做。我们的神经系统的唯一角色是让我们活着，它在不断扫描你的环境以及你的内心世界，寻找威胁的迹象或安全的迹象。当它检测到威胁时（无论是生理上的还是情绪上的），它会将能量从快乐和好奇心转移开，转向保护和生存。当你的神经系统生活在，
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So you can care about someone really, really deeply, be like, super attracted to them, like really into them and still not feel sexual desire. And the flame of that desire is being smothered not by your lack of desire. That's not the thing. It's being smothered by wider factors in your life.
生活在这种高度警惕的状态下，它当然会抑制你的性欲。这对你的生存来说不一定是必要的。就像，它不需要那个。这就是为什么当皮质醇高时，当压力大时，无论你的年龄、恋爱状态、任何东西如何，你感到被唤醒的能力都会骤降。这真正表明的是，身体的压力反应和身体对欲望的容量是同一光谱的两端。当一个被激活时，另一个就无法完全开启。它们都消耗了太多的能量。我认为同样至关重要的一点是，不仅要提及
Our libido, how I heard someone put it, is that it's basically a reflection of how safe we feel in a particular moment. Your ability to feel turned on, to connect, to open up. It depends on whether your nervous system feels calm enough. to let you. Our nervous systems have one role, which is to keep us alive, is constantly scanning your environment and your internal world as well for signs of threat or signs of safety. And when it detects threat, whether that's physical or emotional, it redirects energy away from pleasure and curiosity and towards protection and survival. When your nervous system is living,
当前的压力。创伤在这里扮演的角色就像一整集、多集、甚至整个系列本身。它对性欲的影响是如此显著。如果你读过《身体记得一切》（The Body Keeps the Score）或者听过几个月前我们做的那期关于创伤的节目，你就会知道创伤几乎重写了你的身体识别安全的方式。因此，当亲密关系的可能性出现时，当有人靠近时——比如想跟你亲热，比如在你的脖子上亲吻，以某种方式看着你——你的身体可能会紧绷起来，仿佛在说：上次发生这种情况时，感觉不知所措而且很危险，
living in this state of vigilance, of course it's going to suppress your sexual desire. That's not necessarily necessary for your survival. Like, it doesn't need that. And that is why when cortisol is high, when stress is high, regardless of your age, relationship status, anything, your ability to feel arousal plummets. What this really shows is that the body's stress response and the body's capacity for desire are two ends of the same spectrum. One cannot be fully on whilst the other is activated. They both take up too much energy. I think it's also really crucial to mention that it's not just
所以我们必须离开或关闭这一切。这种情况尤其会发生在一经把亲密关系与混乱、压力、羞耻、痛苦、情感和不可预测性联系在一起的时候。即使没有明确的伤害，身体也已经了解到，完全向亲密关系开放是伴随着风险的。所以那个刹车，我们讨论过的那个刹车，正被紧紧踩下，这不是对你伴侣的拒绝，而是出于生存的需要。你知道，这真的是一件很难熬的事情。而且感觉这就是你以后看待性的方式，这真的很难受。
current stress. The role of trauma here is like a whole episode, multiple episodes, a whole series in itself. The impact that has on sexual desire is so significant. If you've read the body keeps the score or if you've listened to the episode on trauma that we did on that a few months back, you'll know that trauma pretty much rewires how safety is recognized by your body. So when the possibility of intimacy appears when someone moves closer, like wants to make out with you, like kisses you on the neck, looks at you in a certain way, your body might tense up in a way that says last time this happened, it felt overwhelming and it felt dangerous. so we have to either leave or shut this down.
但我向你保证，事实并非如此。你知道，当你发现自己与性欲苦苦抗争时，你的欲望依然存在。只是你的神经系统还没有得到放松的许可。压力和创伤是我们正在谈论的抑制系统的一侧，自我批判也是如此，它甚至使这两种事情的影响更加复杂化。比如当觉得你应该被唤醒，你应该产生欲望，而你没有，这让你觉得自己出了问题，这让事情变得更加困难，对吧？抱歉用了双关语，我懂，但它确实让事情变得更艰难了。有坚实的神经科学证据可以帮助我们理解为什么会这样。基本上，羞耻感会激活大脑中对
And this happens especially if closeness, intimacy was once linked with confusion, pressure, shame, pain, emotional and predictability. Even if there was no explicit harm, the body has learnt that being fully open to intimacy comes with risk. And so that break, that break we were talking about, is being firmly pressed, not as rejection of your partner, but from a place of survival. You know, that's just such a hard thing to endure. And it's so difficult to feel like that's just how you're going to view sex from now on.
生理痛苦做出反应的许多相同区域，包括前扣带皮层，它参与检测排斥、社会威胁、脆弱性。这通常就是为什么我们越是强迫性欲恢复，就越难接近它，因为你真切地感到了某种程度的情感痛苦，仅仅因为你一开始没能做到这一点。这种羞耻感在文化上、社会上、人际关系上对我们的影响是如此之重。它同样是从这个不谈论性的系统中继承下来的，而当我们开始谈论性时，它
And I promise that it's not. You know, when you find yourself struggling with libido, your desire is still there. It's just that your nervous system hasn't been given permission to relax. stress and trauma one side of the inhibitory system we're speaking about so is self-criticism and it kind of compounds the effects of these two things even more like when you feel like you should be aroused you should be turned on and something's wrong with you because you're not it makes it all the more harder right sorry for the pun i know but it does make it harder there's solid neuroscientific evidence to help us understand why this is. Basically, shame activates a lot of the same brain regions that respond to
又让我们对此感到糟糕，并且让性变得如此隐秘，以至于我们只是不知道该如何把它做得更好，不知道如何谈论它，不知道如何以某种不是为了取悦别人的表演的方式去做它。不知道如何进行关于起伏的对话，不知道什么是健康的性生活。你知道最有趣的是，是的，我们可以谈论荷尔蒙。是的，我们可以谈论避孕药，我们可以谈论压力，我们可以谈论所有这些事情。
physical pain, including the anterior cingulate cortex, which is involved with detecting exclusion, social threat, vulnerability. This is often why the harder we try to force libido to return, the more difficult it is to access it because you genuinely feel a level of emotional pain by the fact that you weren't able to do it in the first place. That shame impacts us all so heavily, culturally, socially, relationally. It's been inherited, again, from this system that didn't talk about sex, that then when we did start talking about sex,
但是，就像，性真的需要诚实才能蓬勃发展，它需要当下、脆弱和完全的信任才能蓬勃发展。而我们多年来谈论它的方式意味着这些事情很少出现。所以，你感受到的任何羞耻感都不是你的羞耻。那是社会的羞耻，因为它从不真正允许你谈论它。因为当你谈论时羞辱你，当你没有谈论时也羞辱你，并且让你觉得因此受到了性的压抑或压制。
made us feel bad about it, and that makes sex so silent that we just don't know how to be better at it, don't know how to talk about it, don't know how to do it in any way that isn't a performance for somebody else. don't know how to have conversations about ebbs and flows about what a healthy sex life is. And you know what's so interesting is that, like, yes, we can talk about hormones. Yes, we can talk about birth control and we can talk about stress and we can talk about all of these things.
我们要谈论的最后一件事可能是解释为什么你知道你现在正与性欲作斗争，为什么你真的不享受性、不想做爱，当然就是心理健康。我觉得我应该早点谈论这个，但总比不谈好。说到当下，说到神经系统调节，如果你正在与焦虑或抑郁作斗争，那么这些精神状态是如此巨大、沉重和喧闹。很难处在你大脑的核心，在那里你可以保持平静、亲密并与另一个人在一起。焦虑让你变得过分敏感。抑郁则会钝化所有的感觉。
But, like, sex really thrives with honesty and it thrives with presence and vulnerability and, like, complete trust. and the way that we've talked about it for so many years means that like those things are rarely present. So like any shame you feel is not your shame. It's society's shame for never really allowing you to talk about it. For like shaming you when you do and shaming you when you don't and you feel like sexually suppressed or repressed because of it.
它减弱了所有的潜在预期。这也与多巴胺有关，对吧？尤其是如果你有抑郁症，大脑中的多巴胺（不仅负责快乐，还负责动力和唤醒的神经递质）会减少。问题是，当我们与心理健康作斗争时，这就像是双管齐下，一切都感觉更艰难、更麻木、更困难。性生活也被这摧毁了，而我却无法谈论它。然后你可能会试图自救并开始服药，其副作用可能是残酷的。再次声明，让我们坦诚一点。
one final thing we need to talk about that may be an explanation for why you know you're struggling with libida right now why you don't really enjoy sex don't want to have sex is of course mental health i feel like i should have talked about this earlier but better late than ever speaking of presence speaking of of nervous system regulation like as well if you're struggling with anxiety or with depression like those mental states are so big and heavy and loud it's so hard to be in the heart of your brain where you can just be like still and intimate and with somebody else. Anxiety like makes you so hyper aware. Depression just like dulls all sensation.
当我开始服用来士普（Lexapro）时，我什么感觉都没有。就像我不知道一样，我几个月都没有任何欲望。我得说这绝对是值得的，100%。对我和来说这完全是值得的。但一切都感觉更加黯淡了。这确实很难将身体发生的事情与情感和认知反应联系起来。再次强调，对于某人来说，我认为很多女性都是这种情况。性是心理上的，不是生理上的。
It dims all potential anticipation. And this is also related to dopamine, right? Like especially if you have depression, there is a reduction of dopamine the neurotransmitter responsible not just for happiness but motivation and arousal like in your brain. The thing is, when we're struggling with mental health, it's like this double barrel of like everything feels harder and more numb and more difficult. Sex is also being killed by this and I can't talk about it. And then you may try and like help yourself and go on medication and the side effects of that can be brutal. Again, let's be really candid.
性是认知的，而不是生理的，没有那种当下感和高度情绪体验的元素，这变得非常困难，这只是需要适应的新事物。现在情况好多了。好吧，不是说这次低潮，而是来士普并没有真正对我产生太大影响。所以，如果你正在经历，这绝对是值得的。这只值得与某人交谈，然后说，嘿，我们需要在这里更加刻意，或者我们需要对此进行更多公开的对话，或者只是少做一点，因为我想在心理上照顾好自己，这意味着在这里和那里做出一小部分牺牲，这可能是其中之一。问题是，所有这一切都是如此错综复杂。你可能无法查明
When I went on Lexapro, I had nothing. Like I didn't know, I had no desire for months. I will say it was worth it for sure, 100%. It was totally worth it for me. But everything just felt more muted. And it just made it really hard to connect like what was happening physically with an emotional and like cognitive reaction. And again, for somebody, I think this is the case with a lot of women. Sex is mental, not physical.
到底是什么在此时此刻扼杀了你的性欲。但我们可以讨论如何，我不知道，在不强求的情况下体谅自己，或者在不推开创伤的情况下，或者在不把与某人的亲密关系变成一个项目的情况下。现在，显然我不是性治疗师，我不想过多谈论我自己的经历，因为它们不仅仅属于我，它们还涉及其他人。但我确实想为你简单介绍一下人们推荐的、我读过的、很棒的事情，这些事情触及了更深层的心理学，也许对你来说是一个很好的起点。
sex is cognitive, not physical, not having that like element of presence and like heightened emotional sensation, like made it really difficult and was just like a new thing to adapt to. And it's gotten so much better now. Well, not that with this dip, but like the Lexa Pro doesn't really impact me as much. So like it's totally worth it if you are. It's just worth having a conversation with somebody and being like, hey, like, we're going to need to be more deliberate here or we're going to need to have more open conversations about this or just do this a little bit less because I want to take care of myself mentally and that means a couple of sacrifices here and there this might be one of them. The thing is like all of this is just so intricately layered. You might not be able to pinpoint
我想，与其试图猛踩油门，对吧？第一步通常是自然地放慢速度，这样你的神经系统就不会觉得它需要为你踩刹车了。我们大多数人以一种神经系统根本无法承受的速度在世界上穿行。我们当前的环境就像信息和刺激超载，持续的输入，持续的思考，持续的大脑工作。这令人不知所措。获得快乐要求你做与这一切相反的事情。字面意义上就是给自己更多的时间来过日子并活在当下。这可能会让人觉得非常奇怪和不熟悉，但如果你在战或逃状态中呆了很长时间，
exactly one thing that is killing your libido right now. But we can kind of talk about how to, I don't know, meet yourself where you're at without forcing it or without pushing part. trauma or without, you know, turning intimacy with somebody into a project. Now, obviously, I'm not a sex therapist and I don't want to go too much into my own experiences because they're not just mine, like they involve other people. But I do want to give you a bit of a run-through of things that people recommend that I've read that are amazing, things that touch on deeper psychology, that maybe might be a good start point for you.
恰恰是某一件正在扼杀你性欲的事情。但我们可以聊聊如何，怎么说呢，在不勉强、不强推创伤、或者说不把与某人的亲密关系变成一个任务的情况下，去接纳你当下的状态。显然，我不是一名性治疗师，而且我不想过多谈论我自己的经历，因为这些经历不仅属于我，还涉及到其他人。不过，我的确想向大家大致介绍一下别人推荐的、我读过的那些非常棒的内容，这些内容触及了更深层的心理学，或许能为你提供一个很好的起点。
I think instead of trying to push down on that accelerator, right? The first step is often slowing down naturally so that your nervous system doesn't feel like it needs to put the brakes on for you. Most of us move through the world at a pace that our nervous system was not built for. Our current environments are like information and stimulation overload, constant input, constant thinking, constant brainwork. It's overwhelming. accessing pleasure, asks you to do the opposite of all that. Literally just give yourself more time to live out your day and to be present. This can feel really weird and unfamiliar, but if you spend a long time in final flight,
我认为，与其试图猛踩油门，对吧？第一步往往是自然地慢下来，这样你的神经系统就不会觉得它需要为你踩刹车了。我们大多数人生活的节奏，是我们的神经系统根本无法承受的。我们当前的环境充满了信息和刺激过载，持续的输入、持续的思考、持续的大脑运转。这太让人招架不住了。体验快乐要求你做与这一切完全相反的事情。字面意思上，就是给自己更多的时间去过好每一天，去活在当下。这可能会让人感觉非常奇怪和陌生，但如果你长期处于战斗或逃跑状态中，
in survival mode, just like in a state of stress and arousal because life is so busy for you, just giving yourself time to just move slower, inhabit your body, reconnect with just like the natural flow of things like it's not sexual at all but it's really really intimate this other thing i saw recommended was just like connect with small pleasures that are going to have nothing to do with sex the warmth of a hot shower a really delicious piece of dark chocolate the feeling of your hair between your fingers or the smell of your shampoo the weight of a really snugly blanket on you while the thing you the air con is on, the way your sunlight warms your skin, like when you're on the grass,
在处于生存模式时，就像处于压力和亢奋状态一样，因为你的生活太忙碌了，给自己留出时间放慢节奏、感受自己的身体、重新与万物的自然流动建立联系——这完全与性无关，但却非常非常亲密。我看到的另一个建议是，去感受那些与性完全无关的小确幸：热水澡的温暖、一小块美味的黑巧克力、手指穿过头发的感觉、洗发水的香味，当开着空调时盖在身上厚实的舒适毯子，阳光温暖皮肤的感觉，比如当你在草地上时，
the softness of like your pet's breath, like just all these things. Like, let the world romance you for a little bit. If intimacy feels overwhelming right now, especially with somebody else, like, you can begin here with sensation that literally asks nothing of you, nothing in return. Like, that's going to mean that you don't feel like you're going to be. constantly rejecting intimacy that the only way you can experience intimacy is like if you can have sex and like it's either that or nothing like this is a type of intimacy that like you're not going to let anybody down whether you enjoy it or not it's just there for you to enjoy right like and when
宠物呼吸的柔软，等等。让世界对你进行片刻的浪漫化。如果亲密感在此时让你觉得难以承受，尤其是与另一个人在一起时，你可以从完全不需要你付出任何代价、不需要任何回报的感觉开始。这意味着你不会觉得自己一直在拒绝亲密感，不会觉得体验亲密感的唯一方式就是发生性关系，非此即彼——这是一种不需要你管别人高兴不高兴、无论你是否享受它都只是为了你而存在的亲密感，对吧？当
you begin to notice these sensations rather than rushing past them i think you just give yourself a chance to feel a little bit more in touch with yourself in touch with like your senses and more present. You know, what's the height of slowing down? The height of slowing down is, of course, getting more sleep. Literally just resting more. I saw a stat that said, one extra hour of sleep per night can increase libido by 14% on average from this study.
你开始注意到这些感觉，而不是匆忙掠过它们时，我认为你只是给了自己一个机会，让自己感觉与自己更贴近，与自己的感官更贴近，也更加活在当下。你知道，放慢节奏的最高境界是什么？放慢节奏的最高境界，当然是获得更多的睡眠。字面意思上的多休息。我看到过一个统计数据，这项研究表明，每晚多睡一个小时，平均可以使性欲提高14%。
And I don't know if that result has been replicated, but like, I think it's worth a try. I just like getting more sleep, drinking less alcohol, like so much daily stress and like frustration and irritability that puts like a barrier out between you and pleasure comes from drinking and comes from not getting enough sleep. I've just found at the moment I prioritize those two things. Obviously like sleeping more and not drinking less, I just feel so much better and I feel happier and lighter and I'm going to be more willing to like really get into it.
我不知道这个结果是否被复制过，但我觉得值得一试。我只是喜欢多睡觉、少喝酒。很多日常压力、挫折感和易怒感，在快乐和自我之间筑起了一道高墙，这都是由于喝酒和睡眠不足引起的。我发现只要我目前优先处理好这两件事——显然就是多睡觉、少喝酒——我就会感觉好得多，感到更快乐、更轻松，并且会更愿意真正投入其中。
I also think, you know, it's probably wise just to go and get your bloods done. Go get a panel of bloods. Go to your doctor. There may be something physical that's happening that could be addressed pretty rapidly. Like low iron, maybe you need a change in your birth control, a less intense dosage of antidepressants, some melatonin to help you sleep better that will help you have more energy. Obviously, this is not medical advice, but like there are so many explanations there. And just having more information makes you feel so much better anyways.
我也认为，去查一下血液指标可能是明智之举。去做一套血液检查。去看医生。身体可能存在某种可以相当迅速解决的生理问题。比如低铁、可能需要更换避孕药、减少抗抑郁药的剂量、服用一些褪黑素来帮助睡眠以恢复更多精力。显然，这不是医疗建议，但其中有这么多的解释。而且，仅仅拥有更多信息无论如何都会让你感觉好得多。
like I was diagnosed with PCOS recently and my doctor told me how much it reduces libido and we would, she's amazing and we were just talking about it and how they don't really know why. Of course, they don't. It's female health. But just knowing that, like the way she just said that to me, I was like, oh, I feel so much less silly. I feel so much less like, this is my fault that I just like am not that interested. Sexual health is emotional health, is physical health, is mental health is health. like you're allowed to go to your doctor and be like hey like i would like to be having more sex
比如我最近被诊断出患有多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS），我的医生告诉我这会极大地降低性欲，我们——她太棒了——当时正在讨论这件事，以及为什么他们实际上并不知道原因。当然，他们不知道，这是女性健康嘛。但只要知道这一点，当她那样对我说时，我就想：“哦，我觉得自己没那么傻了。”我不再觉得我对性没那么大兴趣全是我的错。性健康就是情绪健康，就是身体健康，就是心理健康。你可以去找医生说：“嘿，我想拥有更多性生活，
and that's an important part of my life for me so like can you help me with that and they can help investigate what's going on below the surface when it comes to your partner you need to create a shared understanding that intimacy takes many shapes and that you just need to slow down it's not about withdrawing you don't want to reject them you want to be present with you want to do this differently. And you want to be able to talk with them openly and just say like, hey, I don't want to have sex unless it's amazing. Like, I want to have amazing sex with you.
这对我来说是生活中的重要部分，所以你能帮帮我吗？”他们可以帮你调查表面之下的情况。至于你的伴侣，你需要建立一种共识：亲密感有多种形式，你们只需要放慢节奏。这并不是疏离，你不是想拒绝他们，你是想活在当下，想用不同的方式来做这件事。你希望能够与他们公开交谈，直截了当地说：“嘿，除非感觉棒极了，否则我不想做爱。我想和你体验美妙的性爱。
I don't want to have cheap, not good, random sex. I want to be invested in this. And because of that, I just want to figure out a little bit more about what my body responds to and what my body needs. And I love being close to you. I just think, like, we need to explore different ways for that. closeness. You're making it clear that you're not just, you're not rejecting them. And I know that's such a tension point in relationship when one person wants to have more sex than the other person.
我不想进行廉价、不好、随意的性爱。我想投入其中。正因为如此，我只想更多地了解我的身体对什么有反应，我的身体需要什么。我喜欢和你亲近。我只是觉得，我们需要探索其他方式来获得这种亲密感。”你要明确表达，你不仅仅是、你并不是在拒绝他们。我知道在恋爱关系中，当一个人比另一个人性欲更强时，这是一个非常紧张的点。
Normally it's like if you're in a heterosexual relationship, the guy, like for them, sex is very physical. And it can feel like every time you have to be like, no. And that you're really just like insulting them that it's saying something about your relationship. I think having that language of like, I actually, I want to have a really good sex with you. makes it so much better. And obviously, like, you don't need to apologize. You don't need to, like, feel guilty for it. You don't need to protect their ego in any way.
通常情况下，如果你处于异性恋关系中，对于男性来说，性是非常身体化的。这可能会让他们觉得你每一次都必须说“不”，这真的是在侮辱他们，是在暗示你们的关系出了问题。我认为拥有这样的话语表达方式：“实际上，我想和你进行非常棒的性爱”，会让情况变得好得多。显然，你不需要道歉。你不需要为此感到内疚。你不需要以任何方式去保护他们的自尊。
But, like, if you're serious about this person, like, you've got to have open conversations about this that sometimes are, like, a little bit uncomfortable. You're just making it clear. Like, I want this with you. Let's make it amazing. I also had this friend, and I know she won't mind me sharing this, but she was telling me about this thing that her and her girlfriend did.
但是，如果你对这个人是认真的，你就必须就此进行有时可能会让人觉得有点不舒服的公开对话。你只是在表达清楚：我想要和你一起体验这个。让我们把它变得美妙无比。我还有一个朋友——我知道她不会介意我分享这个——她告诉我她和她女友做的一件事，
which was they just took sex off the table entirely for three months and they started to approach it like they were teenagers again or like they were experiencing everything for the first time together like going back through like base one base two like third base and just like focusing on one of those bases like a week at a time and I remember like I got dinner with her and she was like I was like oh how's it going she's like, oh my God, it's amazing. Like, it's kissing week. And, like, all we do is make out. And, like, we know, like, we're not going to have sex.
那就是她们完全把性生活搁置了整整三个月，然后开始像青少年时期的情侣那样重新接近彼此，或者就像一切都是第一次共同经历那样，从头再来，经历一垒、二垒、三垒，每周只专注于其中一个垒位。我记得我和她一起吃晚餐时，我问她：“哦，进展怎么样？”她说：“哦天哪，太棒了。现在是接吻周，我们做的全部事情就是热吻。而且我们知道，我们不会发生性关系。
Like, we just make out. And it's so much fun. It's, like, the anticipation is there, and it feels like there's no pressure. And, like, I kind of think people should steal that exercise from them. Like, they seem like they're having a great time. And I think it's just really rekindling sometimes the excitement and, like, the enthusiasm in a long-term relationship, like, when you've been, with somebody for a while. Speaking to your partner about this is obviously a necessity.
我们只是接吻，这太有趣了。那种期待感就在那里，感觉没有任何压力。”我某种程度上认为人们应该从她们那里借鉴这个练习。看起来她们过得很开心。我认为这确实重新点燃了长期恋爱关系中的兴奋感和热情，特别是当你和某人在一起已经有一段时间之后。与你的伴侣谈论这件事显然是必须的。
Like speaking to them is a version of intimacy. You will actually find that being open with them will probably make you want to have more sex just because you feel more connected. Speaking vulnerably about this with your friends outside the context of your relationship is also important. Like we need to be talking about low libidos or fluctuating libidos more with our friends.
与他们交谈本身就是亲密感的一种形式。你会发现，对他们坦诚相待可能会让你更渴望做爱，仅仅是因为你感觉联系更紧密了。在恋爱关系之外，与朋友就此进行脆弱的交流也很重要。我们需要与朋友更多地讨论低性欲或性欲波动的话题。
Like we are so down to do like the rowdy sex stories and the one-night stands. We're so down to talk about bad sex or the overall feeling we have towards sex, the tips, the tricks, the stories, like, but this is also part of that conversation. You know, and your friends, as much as you should talk about it with your partner,
我们非常乐意谈论那些疯狂的性爱故事和一夜情。我们非常乐意谈论糟糕的性爱或我们对性的整体感觉、小建议、小技巧、各种故事，但这其实也是对话的一部分。你知道，正如你应该和伴侣谈论的那样，你的朋友们，
your friends know a lot about you. They know what you're going through. They know probably a bit more about your past. They know what's happening with your health, with your job, with your ex, they probably have things that they do for themselves as well, if nothing else, that might be able to help you. And I think like when we open up the conversation, like, it's just, everything feels so much lighter.
你的朋友们非常了解你。他们知道你正在经历什么。他们对你的过去可能了解得更多。他们知道你的健康状况、你的工作、你的前任发生了什么，他们可能也有自己的一些应对方法，即便没有别的，也可能会对你有所帮助。我想，当我们敞开心扉开始对话时，一切都会感觉轻松得多。
One of the best conversations I've had recently was with my friends about this very thing. And guess what? It made me realize how common this is. So many of these, like, all these people were in long-term relationships. All of them said the same thing. Like, yeah, this is something that we go through all the time. like yeah one of us wants sex more than the other i love them very much but like it just is what it is and i think when you just talk about it's like this relief of like oh my god you know yeah you're right
我最近进行过的最好的谈话之一就是和我的朋友们讨论这件事。你猜怎么着？这让我意识到这种情况有多么普遍。所有这些——所有人都在长期的恋爱关系中。他们所有人都说同样的话：“是的，这是我们一直都在经历的事情。是的，我们之中总有一个人的性欲比另一个人强。我非常爱他们，但事情就是这样。”我认为，当你把这件事说出来时，会有一种如释重负的感觉：“哦天哪，你知道的，没错，
not everybody is having as much sex and as great as sex as i thought they were you know every relationship is different mine included i want to create the kind of sex and the relationship to sex with both of us that is going to make it really great for us so if you've been listening to this and you've been recognizing parts of yourself in it, I just hope that like this has given you some information or some answers. And if nothing else, a little bit less shame. Just a bit more knowledge about libido as well. And like what might be impacting it in the fact that like you're not cursed. This isn't the end. Especially if you are in your 20s, like the best is yet to come. That's what it sounds like to me. All of these studies that I was reading,
并不是每个人都像我想象的那样拥有那么多、那么棒的性生活。”你知道，每段关系都是不同的，包括我自己的。我想为我们两个创造那种能让我们俩都觉得好极了的性爱和与之相关的恋爱关系。所以，如果你一直在听这个播客，并且在其中认出了自己的部分影子，我只希望这能为你提供一些信息或答案。如果别的没有，至少能减少一点羞耻感。对性欲有更多的了解，以及了解可能是什么在影响它——事实是你并没有被诅咒，这并不是终点。特别是如果你正处于20多岁，最美好的时光还在后头。听起来就是这样。我读过的所有这些研究、
all these articles were like, yeah, 30 and 40 is like where it's at. So like it's only up from here. This is just like, I think a challenge for you to really like go deeper with like, what do I want, what do I enjoy? What turns me on? What's the mental story I need to associate with sex? And how can I like be better at making that part of the sex I'm having so that it's not just like this act for somebody else or it's not just this thing I do out of obligation or it's sense of obligation or because I want to give the impression of intimacy that I want to have the sex that I actually enjoy and that I really want to have. How can I do that? What do I need to pay attention to? So I think that is all we have time for. Again, I hope you enjoyed the episode. I want to thank
所有的这些文章都在说，30岁和40岁才是真正的黄金时期，所以接下来只会越来越好。我认为这只是对你的一个挑战，让你真正去深入思考：我想要什么？我享受什么？是什么让我兴奋？我需要对性抱有什么样的心理叙事？我怎样才能更好地将这一点融入我正在进行的性爱中，让它不仅仅是为别人履行义务，不仅仅是为了完成任务或为了给人一种亲密感的印象而去做的事情，而是去享受我真正喜欢、真正想拥有的性爱？我该怎么做？我需要注意什么？我想这就是我们今天所有的时间了。再次感谢，希望你喜欢这期节目。我要感谢
our research assistant Libby Cobb for her contributions. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram and that you are subscribed or following along wherever you are listening to the podcast right now. It really helps the show to grow and to reach new people. We also have an older guest episode called Sex is Mental, not just physical, with somebody who knows a lot more about this than me and who does really cool things in like the audio erotic space. So if you want to continue listening and you're like on a role with this like topic, you can go and check that out. I'll leave a little link in the description as well. But again, I hope it was informative. And I hope you have great discussions with your partner,
我们的研究助理Libby Cobb的贡献。请确保在Instagram上关注我们，无论你在哪里收听本播客，都要订阅或关注我们。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众很有帮助。我们还有一期较早的嘉宾访谈节目，叫做《性是心理的，而不只是生理的》（Sex is Mental, not just physical），嘉宾是一位比我更懂这个领域、并且在音频情色领域做着非常酷的事情的人。所以如果你想继续收听并且在这个话题上意犹未尽，你可以去听听看。我也会在简介里留一个链接。再次重申，希望这期节目对你有所启发，并希望你与伴侣、
with your friends about about sex and about getting turned on and about intimacy. Until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
与朋友就性、如何被唤起以及亲密感展开精彩的讨论。下次见，保重。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。《Look Back at It》播客。在1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着通过我们的朋友、喜剧演员同仁和最喜欢的作家来理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。
Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations. that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
在那之前，那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
真的不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容惹恼的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去这样做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”互联网侦探大军揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》（即TWO%）。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓：我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客，由真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。